for the last seven years researchers at
the prakash lab at stanford university
have sampled rocks algae mats and ocean
reefs in search of a tiny and mysterious
multicellular organism called trichoplax
trichoplax is a species of placozoa the
simplest animals at the base of the tree
of life
they don't have a nervous system making
them living fossils from a critical time
in life's evolution
when researchers look at trichoplax
under a microscope they were shocked to
see its millions of cells engaged in
complex activity
trichoplax was able to coordinate its
movement strategize how to find food and
even reproduce by ripping itself in two
but how can trichoplax exhibit these
complex behaviors without a brain to
call the shots
the answer could shed light on the
origins of the nervous system
[Music]
traditionally when you think about
intelligence you think of the brain
trichoplax stretches that intuition
stretches your imagination to ask how
intelligent can a collection of cells
with no neurons no muscles actually be
how much intelligence can a mechanical
collective embody
to answer these questions the
researchers tried to understand the
simple mechanics of the trichoplax
starting with the tiny waving filaments
called cilia
cilia i have often described as the atom
of motility for the last 50 years of the
work in ciliary biology and ciliary
biophysics we have thought of cilia as
an actuator that enables swimming
typically in organisms with nerves and
muscles cilia help move fluids within
the body but when the prakash lab
studied the cilia on the underside of
the trichoplax they discovered something
unexpected i explicitly remember a
moment when we started imaging the
organism and literally watch the cilia
what we observed was a walking gate and
the realization was that the organism
does not swim it actually walks
the researchers designed a mathematical
model to measure the orientation height
and beat frequency of each individual
psyllium as it balanced torque from its
neighboring cells with the force of its
attachment to the surface below
the result was a regular pattern of
locomotion that the researchers called
walking
as they walked these cilia cells
exhibited dynamics similar to those seen
in individual neurons when you stimulate
the neuron with a voltage it executes a
spike and that spike passes information
through the network similarly what we
find in this mechanical system for
walking cilia where just the right pull
in the right direction
leads to a transition
of a cilia from a stall state to a
walking state and it actually suddenly
starts firing in the sense that it
starts walking
but just how these individual cilia
cells coordinated their movement
remained a mystery we started to
characterize our work as asking the
question how do you walk with a million
legs how can many of these cilia work
together
when the researchers looked at all the
ciliated cells at once they saw
something they never thought was
possible the cilia synchronized their
movement like a flock of birds
to literally be able to watch
uh this kind of what we end up
describing as a flocking dynamics
was surreal
because you could see it and you know
when i see bird flocks i can imagine aha
there is a controller there is a brain
in there that's making these sets of
decisions
here we are talking about individual
flocks of these in cilia that are
seemingly just connected by springs
and twirling
in remarkably organic ways
you can think about this coordinated
activity like a group of caster wheels
attached by springs
even if they start off facing in
different directions a force applied to
the system will eventually reorient each
individual wheel so that they all point
in the same direction and the system
travels as a whole
similarly each ciliated cell in the
trichoplax bounces up against its
neighboring cells in a dance between
responsiveness and stability
individual cells the researchers found
could self-assemble into collective
systems capable of a wide range of
behaviors including some that allowed
them to be responsive to their
environment
in other words basic mechanics could
give rise to the kind of incredibly
complex behavior we normally expect from
brains
the observation of trachoplax's ciliary
flocking really brought to the fore for
us this idea that mechanical
systems could somehow be intelligent
they could somehow seek out food they
could somehow come to consensus across
many cells and they could somehow find
ways to keep an organism alive as a
whole instead of just its individual
parts trichoplax may have set the stage
for the rise of animals with nervous
systems by taking an important first
step
embodying simple mechanics that work
together to produce complexity
one of the implications of our work is
that it really has pulled us in new
directions as we think about computation
and intelligence in physical matter we
want to make soft robotic
self-oscillators we want to make caster
robots that come to consensus and work
together to make cargo transport and we
want to think about how we can use these
internal dynamics to make predictive
machines and that is very exciting
notion because we have built an entire
world
out of passive materials
what if these materials had just the
tiniest sliver
of so-called intelligence
[Music]